hey what's up I'm Chris Pratt I'm Tom
Mullen we're here with BuzzFeed we're
gonna take a quiz to find out which
venge a Pixar character be most like
yeah which is Marvel superhero and Pixar
character are you a combination I didn't
see that did you see that
which really since you have to Marvel
Super Heroes and two Pixar characters
here is more a test of the test itself
than of us do you think BuzzFeed's
rigged this so that no matter who we
choose is gonna come back with Peter
Parker and he and Chris Hemsworth it for
me and like Thor and Buzz Lightyear and
you for like gusto from all right to me
really yeah I bet you're a great cook
that's true shall we begin
what would you say your most defining
characteristic is your options are
passionate alluring selfless outgoing
caring and loyal all of those things
none of these things go
nuns not an option I'm going yeah I'd
say outgoings pretty good for you I
would say I would say passionate for me
so I'm gonna go there let's go
choose a mythical creature as a sidekick
a unicorn a centaur a pixie a mermaid or
a dragon I know what you're gonna pick
we ready yeah but yeah it'll be a moment
for me you love the oceans and you want
to be a merman
so for me I'm gonna pick oh I get it I
get a sidekick for sure centaur the only
thing with a mermaid is you can only
take your mermaid on water adventures
why not you can take your mermaid on
land adventures when she dries up she
gets legs oh yeah yeah yeah you didn't
know that that's at least based on
splash which is a movie that came out 26
years before you were born not that
right I'm gonna choose a centaur because
you got a bro to arm wrestle with but
also B get tired you could ride him
widget these differences do you relate
to both do I relate to most Mulan
Jasmine rapunzel Belle Elsa obviously
you same Alana
Rapunzel for me yes I wanna cuz she's
always trying to get out into the ocean
that's true that's good I guess I'm kind
of jasmine you know a princess but I
just want to be taken seriously and
wanted my anonymity back
I'm gonna go Oh Belle which one's Belle
that was from um the one with the big
monster
the new Jasmine from gone Jasmine if you
had magical powers what would you do
with them it doesn't dinner with a
famous figure who is no longer living
travel to a fictional land you've only
read about books
switch places with anyone of your
choosing turn into an animal of your
choosing control the weather and spend
an evening with your entire ancestry I
think if you could control the weather
you could turn that into a serious
business like imagine if someone was
getting married and they're like oh no
it's raining can you I can fix it yeah
[ __ ] are Muslim people bill yeah hey
yeah you got that wedding come up with a
shade start the hill you know I could
blackmail people the mobster I myself
could control the weather I'm gonna say
turn into an animal of my choosing
select a famous elf to go on an arduous
adventure with oh I Scott be the guy
from Zelda whoa it may be Legolas though
because he would look after you as well
yeah so in it we party hell yeah we've
got Dobby the house-elf
from Harry Potter and Legolas from the
Lord of the Ring link from The Legend of
Zelda Keebler Elf and help on the shelf
look Keebler elves no he's a dud we
gotta get rid don't think elf in the
Shelf would be much help either no body
in the elf Bobby the house elf
No potentially though cuz he can do
magic that's true like he's a he's a
magic like a porter you'd be like nice
yeah yeah you don't feel bad making him
do stuff I'm what kind of adventure are
we going on an arduous one I'm gonna go
Dobby the house-elf yeah I'm gonna go W
house elf to put your coffees when you
need it thank you God stressful morning
that'll be enough Dobby I would say
that'll be all Dobby what would the
theme song to your adventure be okay
we've got anyway you own are you gonna
sing them all yeah nice you can go
[Music]
young folks by Peter and Bjorn and John
I don't know that one you don't know
that one
no you see who's gonna know young folks
in Old Town Road by a little Mars eggs
oh that's my son's second favorite song
what would yours be I'm gonna go with
you can go your own way I flee with my
born to run by the boss finally you pick
an activity to do with a loved one play
catch go on and drive grab it a drink to
mouth have a heart have a laugh I have a
laugh is the most important one who do
you get star Lord and Sully may I got
Thor and Russell Speigle Chris Hemsworth
whoa I am star-lord slash Sully that's a
good one actually dedicated a leader
uncle and good at everything you do I
mean yes you can be afraid of what you
don't know or understand and sometimes
it takes you a while to open up and
trust those around you not true not true
complete pushover and totally love
everybody I'm a total mark but you have
a big heart yes and a strong moral
compass which makes you a great friend
who people can always count on that's
nice
that's fascist she really does crack you
it thanks man thank you
my wood is on Thor and Russell from up
I'm good-natured poisonous out a good
time I have a magnetic energy and I
always see the best in people but can
sometimes be naive about their true
intention that's actually really true
I'm too trusting sometimes that
everyone's like yeah you have a problem
and I'm also super loyal which is true
I'm pretty Liam yeah it says you're also
powerful
yeah you knew that you'll see the path
will bring powerful and curious and
loyal
thank you very much man I'm proud of you
I've learned a lot about myself today
feel pretty good about that quiz pretty
amazing I'm proud of you
paddy boom thanks